the fast-food chain Burger King is
jumping into the net neutrality game
they've got a new ad and Craig Aaron
from Free Press mentioned this earlier
in the week during our interview and
it's essentially an ad from Burger King
trolling the Trump administration and
the Trump FCC really is repeal of Barack
Obama's the Obama administration's net
neutrality regulations it's a
three-minute ad it shows Burger King
setting up what they call a whopper fast
lane where if you're willing to pay 26
bucks for a whopper you get the whopper
really quickly and if you're willing to
pay less you have to wait a long time
for the whopper to be ready they call it
whopper neutrality and I want to play
just a little bit of the ad for you to
give you a sense number 98 you got the
Walker so you got the slow axis whopper
pass it's on it's on the menu right
there at the fast medium and slow slow
Mbps fast Mbps or hyper fast Mbps Mbps
for standing for making burgers per
second well that's that's how you get a
pass it's the highest priority this is
like a latencies so me like 15 yeah fast
lane slow lane it's like maybe like 15
20 minutes what are you talking about
I reckon Corporation believes that they
can sell more and make more money
selling like chicken sandwiches and
chicken fries and now they're slowing
down the access to the Walker will you
give it an option of a chicken sandwich
or yeah I don't want a chicken say
Robert I want a whopper yeah
okay so it is pretty clever it's pretty
funny the top marketing executive
Fernando Machado said that the company
believes the internet should be like
Burger King restaurants a place that
welcomes everyone and doesn't prioritize
so this is the right message this is the
correct message but it's a company that
wants to sell burgers period right so I
think that it's a good criticism of the
law as it's been changed I don't know
that it fully explains net neutrality
but again it's just Burger King ad I do
think it's really clever and it shows
what would happen if you extrapolate the
principles of no net neutrality into
something else in this case it's
fast-food at the bottom line though they
just want to sell whoppers or whatever
and that's not a criticism it's a
for-profit corporation but I think that
there's definitely other ways that if
Burger King wanted to become activists
in the world of net neutrality they
could sign on to a lawsuit there's other
things that they could do clever ad and
it's good I still won't go to a Burger
King I haven't been there for a very
very long time as that's what I'm most
known for actually not hosting a Buddha
Pakman show but that I haven't been to a
Burger King Wendy's or McDonald's or
subway they used to work at Circuit City
that's big - uh we'll get but we don't
talk about that oh um so anyway I think
that will cut that out don't worry
people won't people won't hear that make
a note to delete that I think that it's
a good effort I like it but ultimately
it's still a company that is trying to
curry favor with some portion of the
population in order to sell more burgers
I think it's okay honestly though I mean
I think this is a net positive because
you're displaying this in front of a
demographic that normally wouldn't see
this type of thing that normally
wouldn't necessarily learn about
neutrality they have people at home
watching television yeah they come
across this ad or you know I saw this
was trending on YouTube right although I
don't know if this is gonna be this is a
three-minute ad and I don't so I don't
think it's gonna be a television ad that
would really be the great thing because
where people need to see this is on
corporate media where net neutrality is
almost not discussed at all that's where
the ad would be key so I that's the
other thing I want to mention which is
yes Burger King invested money in the ad
but they're not investing any money in
putting the ad on television which is
really where the cost would be buying
the airtime I would have loved it if
they said instead of a three-minute ad
we're gonna do a 30 or 60
I can add and then buy placements for it
on television but maybe the ROI on that
wouldn't be quite so good because buying
advertising time on television is pretty
expensive but again I maybe I'm
nitpicking and I should just be glad
that they're even talking about net
neutrality at all I'm glad about it -
yeah I mean maybe maybe they'll foil
this three minute add into a one-minute
ad and put it on television I guess you
never really know do you want to come
clean about because we're talking about
Burger King the McDonald's vegan
breakfast debacle oh yeah I've had
McDonald's being in breakfast before
Lisa's new scandal recently Pat told me
the other day that that morning he had
McDonald's vegan breakfast yeah you're
really putting me on the spot here I
wasn't expecting this I was shaken by it
and almost had to take the rest of the
day off there was almost no show what is
McDonald's vegan breakfast willing it
consisted of a medium hot black coffee
blot totally black no sugar certainly no
milk no cream yep it consisted of the
oatmeal with dried fruit no cream
normally there would be cream normally
there you had it made with what water
instead like I don't look about the
cream option oh okay and their hash
browns
I had three one two three and the hash
browns are naturally vegan as they say
they're baked and oil yeah interesting
fried they must be fried yeah alright so
I think the upshot is after revealing
that I don't think we'll ever hear about
the Keurig scandal again so that I think
has been completely put to bed at this
point yeah but I think that there will
be pretty significant fallout from I
guess there is an argument to be made
that I am supporting a company that
benefits primarily off of the sale of
meats
yeah animal products that's true but at
the same time you know I'm creating a
demand for their non meat and animal
product options yes so maybe they'll
advertise those more although I go more
so quickly I've still not seen good
evidence that McDonald's hamburgers have
meat so I would reserve judgment until I
actually see evidence all right so
Burger King nice job
I'm sure you'll sell more burgers
probably a double benefit to doing this
but when net neutrality is on the radar
of
food companies that is something that I
think we should all be glad about
because normally it would not reach that
level of sort of mainstream attention
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show follow
us there today's program is sponsored in
part by brilliant which is really an
amazing website that lets you engage in
fun and interesting problems and puzzles
in order to learn more about almost
anything related to science math and
engineering it's a really vibrant
community of over five million members
it brings together the expert knowledge
and experience of students and educators
and professionals from all over the
world learning in the presence of an
actual community really makes a
difference and when you use brilliant
you have the company of over five
million brilliant members who share your
curiosity and the curiosity I have as
you know if you watch the program for
math and science and other topics that
are regularly discussed on the program
and the community at brilliant supports
your learning you build a connection
with the subjects that you're learning
by interacting with other learners and
it's really one of the ways that
brilliant sets itself apart from other
educational websites and I encourage you
to go to brilliant org slash david
pakman sign up for free and the first
200 of you who do that who go to
brilliant org slash david pakman will
get 20% off an annual premium membership
one more time
check out brilliant org slash david
pakman